grab a Snickers and make up with your
best friend's crush because we have
Amazon's latest big-budget series Hannah
yes it's been eight years since the 2011
feature of the same name starring
Saoirse Ronan Eric Bana and Kate
Blanchette launched it Blanchette but
this series expands on the story and
delve further into the mystery
surrounding Hannah and her origins so in
this video we're gonna take a look at
Hannah's ending and take a deep dive in
what it could all mean the final episode
is titled you tracks the codename for
the secret project in which children
specifically females are trained since
birth to become the perfect soldier
doctor Kunak even claims that his girls
have a hundred percent obedience a claim
that will later be tested when trainee
249 sides with Hannah but as Eric finds
out in episode 6 the organization behind
this restarted the you tracks program
the year after their original was
destroyed this new program was called
you Trax Regenesis and the girls seen in
the last two episodes are its trainees
they have never set foot in the real
world the original program however is
where the story of Hannah really begins
Erik explains that after serving time as
a soldier in Afghanistan and Kosovo he
returned home and felt directionless he
turned to alcohol getting drunk at bars
with no prospects for the future until
he was approached by a woman named
Marissa wiegler Marissa at this time
worked for an organization with members
at the highest levels of government
members which she says can make things
happen she recruits Erik with an odd
task get women to sign over their
unwanted babies to the program at the
same time a young woman named Joanna had
a brief fling with a man named Emile
prana and got pregnant this is the man
Hanna later meets and comes to know as
her biological father
it's these dire situations that bring
Erik and Johanna together Erik hangs
outside abortion clinics cuz you know
that's normal and asked the women there
for coffee in 20 minutes of their time
time he hopes he can use to make them
reconsider oh and there's probably a
substantial amount of money involved
there's a great scene later on when
Joanna comes to ask for her baby back
where Erik is interrupted in the middle
of one of these coffees with another
woman in the process of signing over her
baby during this time Erik falls in love
with Joanna but this is something we
never actually see in the show Joanna
wants her baby back and even threatens
to go to the police if she doesn't get
way Eric decides to take matters into
his own hands and uses his skills as an
ex-soldier to infiltrate you tracks in
take Hannah back the plan is successful
but after being chased by Marissa and
her men Johanna is killed while escaping
and Eric and Hannah are forced to live
in the forest for 16 years in order to
avoid being found out by Marissa and the
organization you see after the youth
tracks program was compromised
Marissa received instructions to burn
down the entire facility which also
meant administering lethal injections to
all the babies and disposing of their
bodies in the incinerator this is
something that haunts Marissa throughout
the show
there are several scenes in which the
sounds of crying babies torment her
Marissa tells her bosses that the
situation has been taken care of and
that Eric Hanna and Johanna all died in
that car crash but 16 years later when
she hears of a young girl breaking into
a satellite with arvo hope or arvo she
knows she must capture Hanna and Eric
for good they are the last threads that
link the organization to this project
and if word of a secret program which
raises genetically enhanced child
soldiers got out it would be devastating
but let's talk about this organization
for a second who or what is it well it's
heavily implied that you Trax is a
top-secret CIA program authorized at the
highest levels but at the same time
could be denied if word ever got out
about it that is unless Eric and Hanna
exposed it to the world the u.s. style
military gear and outfits also suggest
that it is American and in the movie
version it's confirmed as being CIA the
purpose of you Trax was to design and
train super soldiers this begins at the
genetic level where DNA was enhanced to
give these soldiers improved senses
Hanna an trainee 249 for example have
heightened hearing smell agility and
strength these soldiers are also
intensely obedient such a force would be
a valuable asset to any army the one
thing that's never explained however is
why only women perhaps because women
make for less obvious spies let me
explain we have an interesting scene in
which the girls learn American state
capitals and excerpts from the
Declaration of Independence leading me
to believe that these girls are being
trained to assimilate into American
society perhaps to spy and take down
American citizens after all you track
sounds a lot like
you track but with henna and two four
nine escaping and the rest of the girls
taken to an unknown base called
Wilberforce we see two of the girls
share an interesting look if there is a
season two we'll likely see these two
awaken to their predicament Erik and
Hannah's attempt to save the girls isn't
quite successful only two four nine goes
along with Hannah and Erik succumbs to
his wounds his dying words are leave me
with her referring to Johanna whose
grave they visited earlier in the
episode in the final confrontation
Marissa kills Jerome Sawyer the new
leader of you tracks and tells Hannah
that she is a friend she also sets
herself up to get her old job back she
calls Norris Jerome's secretive boss who
we never see and tells her that Erik
shot and wounded her of course that's a
lie she shoots herself my guess is that
this is all part of her journey of
atonement for what she did back in 2003
moments before this we see her walking
down the burning u tracks hallway and
the sounds of babies crying haunt her if
Marissa returns for season two she'll
probably team up with Hannah and two for
nine to take down you tracks once and
for all
Hannah and 2 for 9 venture out into a
field and 2 for 9 remarks on how
beautiful it is this is her first time
outdoors experiencing the world and it's
beautifully ironic that a show which
began in a forest also ends in one so
what did you guys think of Hannah I want
to hear your comments below and make
sure to give the video a like and
subscribe because I have more videos on
the way
you can also message and follow me on
Twitter at think story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much